[Music]
my name is claudia witt i'm a medical
doctor and scientist
at the university of zurich i serve as a
co-director of the digital society
initiative
this is where we are at the moment in
the former office of
albert einstein and at the charity
medical school in berlin
i do some of my digital health studies
and that's why i'm so happy that both
institutions signed the cooperation
agreement and digital health plays a big
role in my life
as a scientist but also as a medical
doctor in my clinic for integrative
medicine it's a university hospital
[Music]
medicine like our whole society is
undergoing a fundamental shift
it's becoming more and more digital and
especially during the corona pandemic
this movement has
really accelerated and mobile health
applications
are a big field in medicine they play an
important
role it's a growing field and this also
includes all the apps we are using so
you might have on your smartphone
apps where you track your physical
activity
your nutrition and even perhaps
objective parameters like your heart
rate
and i assume my heart rate is a little
bit higher at the moment
and i can even track it and it is
and we also know that digital health
applications can do
so much more
i'd like to use the video of the
digitalization initiative
of zurich to explain a little bit what
the citizens can expect in the future
from modern health care after the family
breakfast
grandmother aline is doing her morning
routine that includes a digital health
check
a personalized tool recommends her how
to adapt
physical activity and nutrition two
things that are important to her
because she has diabetes her primary
care doctor
analyzes the data and is supported by
artificial intelligence
all aspects of data protection are well
regulated
in the future the relevant partners
play together and grandmother aline
feels confident
to use the tools this looks all so easy
so elegant so well orchestrated
so healthcare might be easier and it
might be
even easier to scale it which means more
people can have access
to good healthcare in the future for
lower costs
so we have opportunities within this
movement but we also have challenges
and there is this big area of data
privacy data protection and data
ownership
and a lot of issues are really not
solved at the moment
so when we download many of those health
apps
which are free of charge but they
collect data
and some of the app business models are
even based on
selling data and i'm pretty sure that
not every user is really aware of it
and the other part is really the linking
of data
so we have these apps we have the
electronic health records and so on
but how do we get it to the point that
the right data is
in time at the right place and that we
have also the amount of data
which we still can oversee and this
means in the future we also have to take
a step back
and have a more conceptual view how all
these developments fit properly together
and last not least we have really to
think about
the barriers to digital health care
because when we think about digital
competency
we include a new aspect here and we have
to find solutions that everyone has
access to health care in the future too
[Music]
healthcare apps are a huge market and it
can get really confusing when you go
into one of the upstairs and it's hard
to choose which one is the right one are
they effective
are they safe in medicine we are usually
very strict if it comes to medical
devices
if it comes to therapeutics they always
have to show
that they are effective and that they
are safe
so when now healthcare apps really
replace
some of the diagnostics or even
therapies
do they also have to show that their
work and that they are safe
i say yes but and the butt
means that the framework how we do
research in medicine
is a very tightly regulated framework
this has been developed over decades
even small
changes take many years to get
implemented
and then we have on one hand side this
very fast
moving and on the other hand sides a
slow process doing research
and this shows that it is really
difficult to get the two together
i just want to give an example i have
done research on a mobile health
application
providing acupressure for menstrual pain
we published the results it was
effective it was safe
and the app was already outdated and
this means we have to find new solutions
how to do this research how to
implement these things and we need
really the right balance between
innovation and safety of our healthcare
and there are new frameworks on the way
and germany is a good example
at the moment because the digital supply
act or also called the digital health
application ordinance
is a framework where a health app
can be introduced into the market and it
is even paid by the health insurance
companies
while it is evaluated these apps need to
be certified and show some preliminary
data
and then it's really in parallel the
evaluation and the reimbursement and
after one year there is a final decision
if it will be part of the healthcare so
we need more of these solutions in the
future
[Music]
for better integration we need for sure
more research
and we all know that research has more
impact if we do it internationally
if we do it interdisciplinary and this
was also reason for us
to sign this collaboration agreement
between the university of zurich and the
charity universities medicine berlin
and within this work we are doing the
opportunities and the challenges play an
important role
and for the future we need a better
balance between
the regulations and innovation but
also really weighting the opportunities
and risks that are in the field and
important future topics are to develop
more suitable
evaluation frameworks to think about
more suitable regulations that is really
reflecting the new developments and
we have to think about the barriers to
digital health care
and for this we need to train the
medical
professionals the next generation but
also the current
generation but also our citizens
and we have also to understand that the
inter-professional care team will change
because the digital aspects and just
thinking about
artificial intelligence about robotics
perhaps in the future
these things are really part on eye
level within an inter-professional care
team
and these are key developments for the
future and we as universities
we want and we have to contribute to
that
[Music]
for us it fits at this year's berlin
science week is digital
because it fits nicely together with our
topic of interest
and we have prepared two contributions
here
one of them is an online only workshop
and in this online
only workshop we will focus on how can
digital house contribute to pandemic
mitigation
and our colleagues from the university
of zurich and the charity universities
medicine berlin
will really show some of their cutting
edge research in this area and the other
is a hybrid panel discussion which
hopefully initiates a
vivid discussion about health apps curse
or blessing
and here we will have panelists
representing the science
the healthcare sector politics
startups but also the citizens
contributing to this topic
and i'm really looking forward to see
you there
[Music]
you